[Music]
so at this moment in time the u.s. was
certainly not known as any kind of big
running power right and was seventy well
no like it that at the beginning of like
this journey there wasn't a lot of
science and understanding about how to
train nobody nobody knew I don't think
people had ideas but it was one of those
things that it was all it was all well
he did that and he won a gold medal so
we should do that right but no real
thought it was very little science
behind it very little experimentation
and that was the thing that really sort
of separated Bob Larson early on from
everybody else because he he ended up at
San Diego State University and iego for
the most part started in Minnesota on a
farm with no running water and no
electricity family moves to San Diego
when he was 11 years old and so he grows
up in San Diego ends up at San Diego and
runs in high school ends up at San Diego
State and it's running at San Diego
State and is really interested in
physical education and what we now call
kinesiology and ends up getting to know
this professor named Fred cash who is
doing some of the first studies on human
cardio health because at the time when
we talk about running not being
something people did he was just didn't
exercise I mean the ideas adults so the
idea it was thought that if you strained
your heart after the age of about 35
that was like a very dangerous thing
Friday that was the sort of risk massive
cardiac catastrophic event
uh-huh and so nobody I mean you think
about that and this was not very long
ago this just like a little more than 50
years ago maybe 50 years ago and at that
time you know we're sending rockets to
them you know we're sending people to
the moon where the Russians actually
have a cell phone at this point you're
they have it they have invented a phone
that can fit in your pocket so it was
sort of like the first cell phone and
the modern map of Europe was kind of
laid out like modernity had happened and
yet when it comes to a cardiac health we
are in the complete dark ages I mean to
me it's completely baffling and so then
there's this guy Fred cash is doing this
studies and he's having these adults in
San Diego come a few evenings a week to
San Diego State and he's telling them to
run and he's taking there and he's
measuring their heart rates and what
he's finding is that the more they run
the more their heart rates are going
down that there becomes that their
hearts are becoming more efficient
mm-hmm and Bob at the time is a college
runner and he's training in summers and
in summer as he does this really radical
thing which is he goes and he runs on
trails and he runs on roads cuz he's not
running around the track all the time
and he does that and he men he's working
with Fred cash and looking at this lab
and he has like this aha moment where he
thinks yeah that's actually what I'm
feeling I feel like the more I run the
longer I run the more efficient I feel
the better it is it's so hilarious
because it's so self-evident and obvious
now to think that that was not something
that people were aware of at that time I
mean like Salk had invented the polio
vaccine and yet people didn't realize
the heart was a muscle like any other
muscle like you know do bicep curls your
biceps get bigger but work out your
heart it might die I think it doesn't it
doesn't make sense but that was the idea
no the heart is just a muscle like any
other muscle exercise it and it will
become stronger and it will become more
efficient so conventional wisdom at this
time pre you know this epiphany was for
track and field athletes what or
cross-country athletes just go to the
track and do what I mean how are they
training at that time you basically had
to sort of I mean I'll call them schools
but one of the schools was really like
very much in its infancy that would be
the the Lydiard school
Lydiard was this coach from New Zealand
who Bob Bowerman at at Oregon we're
going to visit and had come back with
with or Lydiard has the first sort of
jogging group um in New Zealand it put
and his idea was volume you know run you
got to run more than a hundred miles a
week but it wasn't really focused on
intensity it was mainly focused on the
volume and his mantra was trained on
strain so then he had that school on the
one side and then on the other side you
had the sort of traditional Europeans
Emile's data pack was their hero because
he's the only guy the one the 5,000 the
10,000 on a marathon in the Olympics and
Zatopek and all the sort of Zatopek
disciples were obsessed with intervals
so that was go to the track and do half
mile intervals or quarter mile intervals
or you know at the most three quarters
maybe everyone smile you'd do some mile
repeats but it was largely you know
Zatopek would do these these crazy
quarter-mile training sessions where he
would do like 60 or 65 quarter miles all
of them in like 65 seconds with with you
know a minute rest right in between and
so Bob comes along and his idea what he
eventually happens a pawn is a sort of
middle ground his two questions were why
do the long runs have to be so slow and
why do the intervals have to be so short
what if we try to go hard for a long
period of time what if you go to what he
starts talking about as your threshold
you're an edge go to that spot right
before you're gonna become exhausted if
you go at that pace for too long a time
and try and stay there stay there for a
mile today stay there for a mile and a
half tomorrow and slowly build up and
that becomes known what we all call
today
right sort of lactate threshold training
that moment that place where if you go
any harder its unsustainable but if you
go just a little bit easier it's just a
little bit too comfortable like finding
that edge and training at you know at
that for as long as possible I'm trying
to expand your ability to maintain that
pace right and it's uncomfortable I mean
the idea is worst right you're at if
you're at a place you're at a place
where you're not comfortable but the
idea is to teach your body and teach
your mind really how to be comfortable
with being uncomfortable and and that
that's okay
right it's okay if you're afraid die
you're not gonna die it's okay if you're
afraid of it because we're all probably
afraid of it it's not you know it's a
learned behavior to go to the place that
makes you uncomfortable and to stay
there and to think don't slow down
actually try and go a little bit faster
see if there's one more click I can get
to and that was really that's sort of
the central revelation of what he had
his runners doing and it was all
measured I mean he would taking their
pulse rates it wasn't he would have
groups of runners he would he would do
you know he had a control group and then
he had the experimental group and he
take their pulses ahead you know in the
middle of the runs he would see how much
how much they were straining how much
these guys are straining and they would
look at the results and who was getting
better and that's what he came upon so
his his methodology he was seeing he was
seeing bigger gains and more compressed
periods of time than control groups or
people that were training in accordance
with these other methodology definitely
yeah it's interesting because all three
of those modalities there's wisdom to
all of them I mean the sort of initial
you know volume you know concept I mean
that's sort of the legacy of that is
kind of the math atone method like
that's I trained with that like all the
time like building building that
efficiency from the ground up as opposed
to the top down which is what happens
when your threshold training
and the interval training like now I
feel like in modern times the best you
know approach I mean depending upon
distance and you know what level you're
at is some combination of all of those
yes and that's the thing you have to do
I mean now everybody says you know
you've got to have three elements to
your training you gotta you know you
have to have you gotta have volume you
gotta have you know those threshold runs
or I'm sure if you're cycling same thing
or if you're swimming the same main
threshold swims and then you have to do
you know some of those short intervals
the workouts and stuff you don't have to
build build it from all three but while
you're doing that if you're interested
in distance running if that's your thing
the intervals probably shouldn't be too
short yeah and the and the long runs
shouldn't be too slow if you have go I
mean if your goal is just to finish then
you know suppose you want who cares yeah
I mean but if you are really focused on
or even slightly focused on improvement
and getting faster and Ivan and I will
say I've never met I've never met
someone who ran a race and then didn't
say I wonder if I could do it fast
uh-huh that's just like a very I just
feel like that's a human it's a very
human thing and so so if you ever have
that that thought I mean that's the kind
of thing I'm speaking to here right that
drive that we have
[Music]